estás llenando charolas para hacer cubos
de hielo te das cuenta que cada charola
puede recibir la misma cantidad de agua
pero tiene distintos números de cubos de
hielos posibles por hacer la charola
azul
hace 8 cubos de hielo de igual tamaño la
charola rosa hace 16 cubos de hielo de
igual tamaño vamos a dibujar las dos
charolas primero dibujemos la charola
azul
pensemos en que tiene esta distancia
esta será la charola azul
nos indican que esta charola azul tiene
capacidad para hacer 8 cubos de hielo de
igual tamaño así es que haremos la
división aquí
y si volvemos a dividir tendremos
una vez más a la mitad y entonces
tendremos 8 cubos de hielo del mismo
tamaño que estos son el perfecto mismo
tamaño porque tenemos estos 8 cubos de
hielos que se pueden hacer en la charola
azul ahora nos dicen que la charola rosa
tiene la capacidad de recibir la misma
cantidad de agua por lo que vamos a
dibujar nuestra charola rosa del mismo
tamaño porque va a recibir la misma
cantidad cantidad de agua me trabo a la
hora de dibujar y hablar
y tenemos entonces está nuestra charola
rosa voy a volver a colocar las
divisiones para pensar que tenemos 8
ocho divisiones
igual que la charola azul solo que
nuestra charola rosa puede hacer 16
cubos por lo que cada uno de estas
digamos fosas para hacer los cubos de
hielo la dividir en dos y así tendremos
vamos avanzando
y de esta manera estamos a punto de
pensando que cada uno de estos 16 huecos
tienen exactamente el mismo tamaño
entonces podemos ahora continuar con
nuestro problema porque ya planteamos la
charola azul y la charola rosa nos dice
que ponemos tres cubos de hielo de la
charola azul en la bebida tomaremos
entonces uno
tres de estos cubos para la bebida
cuántos cubos de hielo de la charola
rosa necesitarías para igualar
exactamente la cantidad de hielo tenemos
varias formas de poder resolver esto y
podemos pensarlo de manera gráfica o de
manera con los números tenemos primero
con los números tenemos aquí uno dos
tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho
posibilidades
de cubo de hielo de los cuales estamos
tomando tres lo que literalmente indica
que tenemos tres octavos tomados para la
bebida si nosotros tenemos tres octavos
y estamos buscando un número equivalente
pero pensado desde los dieciseisavos que
tenemos en esta charola vamos a
preguntarnos tres octavos
cuanto equivaldrá o cuántos cubos de la
charola
cubos necesitaré para igualar la
cantidad de tres cubos de la charola de
8 y para esto regresaremos a la parte
visual este cubo de hielo está ocupando
el espacio de dos cubos en la charola
rosa este cubo estará ocupando otros dos
espacios en la charola rosa y este cubo
azul estará ocupando otros dos espacios
en la charola rosa de tal manera que
tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6
dieciseisavos para tener exactamente la
misma cantidad de hielo en ambas
charolas por lo que podemos decir que
tenemos seis dieciseisavos así lo vemos
de manera visual esto tiene sentido sí
sí tiene sentido porque si nosotros
multiplicamos el numerador por dos
tendremos tres por dos igual a seis y de
la misma manera multiplicaremos el
denominador por dos tenemos ocho por dos
es igual a 16 y con esto tenemos un par
de fracciones equivalentes que nos
representan que tenemos la misma
cantidad pero manejada uno desde octavos
y otro desde 16 años de esta manera si
nos preguntan cuántos cubos de hielo de
la charola rosa necesitamos para igualar
exactamente la cantidad de hielo
sabremos que necesitamos
1 2 3 4 5 6 y con eso tenemos
exactamente la misma cantidad de hielo
que la charola azul